وانا ارجع هنا ليس ضروره ان يكون يعني لا
يوجد
اشير الى هذه الصور لاننا نتحدثنا عنها
مرارا هذا هو اثمار من خير وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي اليميني همم يقوم
بزياره الى موقع تنفيذ العمليه في مستوطنه
نبي يعقوب في القدس
الذي سيعقد اجتماع الامنيا لبحث الرب بعد
قليل هذا اثمار طبعا همم كان هناك
انتقادات لتصرفاته بشكل كبير منها اقتحام
همم باحه المسجد الاقصى وهو ما يستفز
مشاعر الفلسطينيين همم
طبعا كان هناك انتقادات
لتصرفات الوزير
بانه همم يقوم باستفزاز مشاعر الفلسطينيه
بشكل كبير وكان هناك انتقادات طبعا
مشاهدينا اللي لو ان هذه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه حتى من همم المعارضه
الاسرائيليه لكونها همم تحتوي على عناصر
همم يمينيه همم بشكل كبير جدا في هذه
الحكومه
اذا تشاهدون على الشاشه ايضا
بزياره موقع العمليه التي وقعت ثمانيه قتل
اسرائيليين على الاقل وعشره جرحه ااا طبعا
حاله غضب همم لدى الاسرائيليين من هذه
الحصيله همم من القتلى بعد هذه العمليه في
القدس
وبالتحديد في مستوطنه
الذي يعقوب
التي تقطنها غالبيه من اليهود المتدينين
كما تتابعون حاله غضب بين الاسرائيليين
باتجاه اثمار بالقصير وزير الامن
الاسرائيلي
رسائل النوم او رسائل تاييد
لاثمار بن خفير ااا
طبعا كان هناك لون للشرطه الاسرائيليه
لتاخرها في الوصول الى مكان تنفيذ العمليه
التي اوقعت ثمانيه قتلى اسرائيليين على
الاقل واصابه 10
اخرين هناك شد على اليد هنا على ما يبدو
همم من انصار اثمار بن خيره وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي همم
[موسيقى]
هل هي صور مشاهدينا قبل قليل
بعد زيارته الى موقع تنفيذ العمليه في
مستوطنه نذيع يعقوب
طيب زياد